- [Announcer] This program
is a presentation of UCVT
for educational and
noncommercial use only.
(upbeat music)
- Welcome to a Conversation with History.
I'm Harry Kreisler
of the Institute of International Studies.
Our guest today is Steve Squyres
who is the Goldwin Smith
professor of astronomy
at Cornell University.
He is the chief scientist
and principle investigator
of the Mars Exploration Rover Mission.
That mission is described
in his book Roving Mars.
Steve, welcome to Berkeley.
- It's a pleasure to be back.
- [Harry] Where were you born and raised?
- I was born and raised
in Southern New Jersey,
right across the river from Philadelphia.
- Looking back how did your parents
shape your thinking about the world?
- Oh, they shaped my
thinking in an enormous way.
I have been a scientist
as long as I can remember.
When I was six years old I
considered myself a scientist
I just wasn't a very good one yet.
Both my parents were scientists.
My father is a chemical
engineer, actually.
He got his doctorate from MIT.
My mother was a zoology
major at Wellesley.
That was where they met in Boston.
When I was growing up
when I was a little kid
I was always interested in science.
I would go to my parents with questions.
Dad would handle all
the physical sciences,
and mom would handle all
the life sciences stuff,
so if I was looking through
a microscope at cells
I would talk to my mom,
and if I was building a weather
station out in the backyard
I would talk to my dad.
They were both very encouraging,
and remarkably tolerant.
I was one of those kids I
had a little chemistry set,
and I would do experiments
that would, sometimes,
not do great things, you know,
things would blow up
and burn and so forth.
They put up with a lot.
- I get the sense that not
only were you developing
your science curiosity,
but also somewhere you
were getting the notion
of being an explorer.
- Yeah, very much so.
When I was young I was fascinated
by the history of exploration.
I would read books about exploration
of the Arctic and the
Antarctic, mountaineering.
I love climbing mountains myself.
I grew up in New Jersey where it's flat,
but we took a family vacation to Colorado
when I was eight years old,
and I just fell in love
with mountaineering,
and climbing mountains.
What initially drew me to
geology was I like science,
I like climbing mountains
I figure I could do
science in the mountains,
so that was what initially
pulled me into geology.
The other thing, of course,
was I grew up in the '60s,
and that's when Mercury and Gemini,
and Apollo were happening.
I was 13 years old
when Aldrin and Armstrong
walked on the moon.
That was what always fascinated me.
- What about popular
culture, movies and so on,
shows like Star Trek
did they have an impact?
- Yeah, actually less so.
I've never been a big
follower of science fiction.
I mean, I was aware of that stuff,
but it wasn't science
fiction that drove me so much
as it was real exploration
as it was happening
with things like Apollo,
and then reading through
the history of exploration,
and Cook, and Columbus,
and Magellan, and Scott,
and Amundsen, and the Antarctic,
and that sort of stuff.
- What about school
before you went to college
were you experiencing
good science education,
or was it really the home environment?
- It was more the home environment.
I mean, I went to high school,
and I took sort of the
standard courses that you take,
but to do the kind of
science that I wanted to do
when I was young I wanted to
design my own experiments,
and make my own mistakes.
It was really more at home
the really interesting science that I did.
The things that I learned
I learned largely from
my parents, actually.
- [Harry] Where did you do
your undergraduate work?
- I was at Cornell University.
I was at Cornell as an undergraduate,
as a graduate student
and now as a professor.
I tried to escape from
the place a couple times,
and didn't succeed either time,
but when I was an undergraduate
I was a geology major.
I'm a professor of astronomy now,
but at the time I was doing just straight
bang it with a hammer geology.
- What did you do your scientific work
as a graduate student on
did you do a dissertation?
- Yeah, I was very fortunate
in that I went to grad school
I was in grad school from 1978 to 1981.
That was right when the Voyager mission
to Jupiter and Saturn was happening.
I was very lucky that
I was able to work with
the Voyager science team,
and I wrote my thesis on
two of the moons of Jupiter.
It was just fantastic
very formative experience for me
working on that mission it
was an incredible experience.
- Was it the excitement of discovery,
or was it that all of your
education and your background
was meeting in the right place to be?
- Everything was perfect.
I mean, all my background,
all my interests
were beautifully focused
on trying to do the geology
of these moons of Jupiter,
and then I got to just be
there and be part of it.
We went from the moons of Jupiter
being these little points
of light, literally,
that you could study in a telescope
into worlds that you could map,
and do geology on in 48 hours.
It was phenomenal.
- Before we talk about the Mars mission
I want to get your insights
on being a scientist.
What is the skillset
beyond the obvious
that really makes the kind
of work you do possible?
- Yeah, I mean, there
are the obvious things,
but I think the most
important characteristic
that you need to have to
be a success as a scientist
is just a deep and fundamental curiosity
about how the world works,
and science is figuring stuff out.
I always say that being a geologist
is like being a detective
at the scene of a crime.
There are clues and the
clues are in the rocks,
and you're trying to read those clues,
and figure out what happened at this place
three billion years ago on Mars.
If you don't have that curiosity,
I don't care how smart you are.
I don't care how good you are at math.
I don't care how well educated you are,
or where you went to school
if you don't wake up in the morning
wanting to go figure out stuff
you're not gonna really
be a good scientist
because that's the key it's
having that curiosity drive you.
- The curiosity, and also
involved in that I guess
is posing the right questions.
- Yeah, actually, that's
a really important point
is that if you look at
scientists and you ask yourself
who's successful and who's not,
a big part of it really is
picking the right questions to work on.
That has many dimensions.
One dimension just the practical one
is that if you want to do science,
especially, big complicated science
you need funding, you need money,
so you got to pick a problem
that somebody's willing
to pay to have solved,
and you got to write a proposal,
and you got to get the
funding to get that done,
and that's just a practical reality,
but the other thing is
if you want to have an
impact as a scientist
you have to pick the problems that matter,
the ones that are fundamental
to our understanding.
Those are sometimes not as obvious
as you might think they would be.
I mean, there are some that are obvious.
Is there life on Mars?
That's an easy one, okay?
There are others that
aren't obvious at first,
and then somebody finds
something cool and off you go.
There's an element of intuition
I guess I would call it.
Having a sense of what's the
important stuff to work on.
Another thing is you need
to be able to pick problems
that actually are sort of solvable.
I mean, there are important,
exciting problems out there
that are just intractable,
and if you spend 20 years of your career
banging your head against a brick wall,
and the wall doesn't fall
down you've wasted 20 years,
so you really want to be
sure that you pick problems
that you can actually make
some headway on as well.
- I think I read an interview with you,
or maybe it was in the book
that part of your transition
from geology to space was about,
well, there would be more
interesting questions
out in space than there were
on the ground here in geology.
Is that a fair restatement
of what you said,
or is that what you meant?
- I wouldn't say it quite
that way, but you're close.
This really gets to my
passion for exploration
as well as just pure science.
I went into geology it was
the field that I chose,
and spent several years
getting trained to do geology,
but after about three years
of that as an undergraduate
what I came to realize
is that the geologists
who have been working on this planet
for a couple hundred years
have done a pretty darn good
job of figuring things out.
While there is enormously
important and interesting science
that remained to be done
because of I was driven
by the desire to explore
as well as to do science
I craved working in a field
where there were things that
had just never been seen,
where there were problems
that hadn't even emerged yet.
I was sort of drifting towards maybe doing
some kind of work in the deep ocean
because the deep ocean
is one of the most poorly
understood portions of our planet,
but then I got exposed
to planetary exploration.
I took a course
at Cornell that was being
taught by a professor there
who is a member of the science team
for the Viking mission to Mars.
This was going on at the
time in the late '70s.
I was an undergraduate it
was a graduate level course.
We were expected because
it was a graduate course
to do some kind of pieces
of original research
for our term paper,
so a few weeks into the
semester I'm thinking to myself
I better start working on my
term paper so I go to this room
where all the pictures
from Mars were kept.
This is, of course, before CD-ROMs,
and Internet and all that kind of stuff,
and the pictures were just on
rolls of photographic paper.
I remember walking into
that room and sitting down,
and looking at these pictures of Mars
that hardly anybody in the
world had ever seen before
I was gonna spend 15 or 20
minutes flipping through pictures
I walked out of that room four hours later
knowing exactly what I wanted
to do with the rest of my life
because this was the blank canvas
that I had been looking for.
I mean, I didn't understand
what I was looking at in these pictures,
but the beauty of it was nobody did.
That was what appealed to me.
- Now in a project like the Rover project
it's not just scientists
it's also engineers.
- [Steve] Oh, it sure is you bet.
- In your book you make an interesting
distinction between the two.
Tell us a little about engineers,
and compare them with the work of science,
which you've just described.
- Yeah, it's quite different, I mean,
scientist are truth seekers.
You're trying to understand
how the world works,
how the universe works.
That's what drives you
it's the curiosity about how things work.
Engineers are creators, they're inventors,
they're tinkerers, they're
people who build stuff,
and their goal is to build
something that works,
and does so in an elegant,
successful fashion.
Engineers because they're
actually building real things
have to grapple with certain realities.
You have a finite budget
to build something.
You maybe have a finite schedule.
Certainly, if you're sending
spacecraft off to Mars
you have a launch date,
and you better make that launch date.
Engineers have to make compromises.
They might have a concept in their head
for what would be the most
elegant machine you can imagine
to accomplish this task,
but it costs too much,
it would take too long
to build it, et cetera,
so you have to come up
with something that works.
So there's this very
interesting interaction
that takes place between
scientists and engineers
where the scientist has some concept for
I want a machine that will do this,
so I go and talk to an
engineer and the engineer says,
well, we could try that
let's see what we can do,
but then, of course, the
scientist wants it to be perfect,
the engineer wants it to work,
and those two are sort of at conflict
with one another in the
real world when you have
these schedule constraints
and budget constraints.
So there's this very interesting interplay
that goes back and forth
between scientists.
It can be wonderful or
it can go very wrong.
When it's wonderful as it
was on our rover mission
there's this wonderful creative
interplay that takes place.
What I found was that
the key to making it work
is that the scientists need
to learn some engineering,
and the engineers need
to learn some science.
We put a lot of effort on our
project into achieving that.
I give a whole lot of credit
to our project manager
the engineer who sort of
led the engineering team
because he kind of instilled
the view among the engineers
that were doing this for the science.
I tried very hard with my
science team to hammer into them
that if engineering doesn't
work we get nothing,
so we got to learn some engineering,
and we got to respect
what the engineers do.
I'll bet you, I'll bet you
that if you came and you sat in
on one of our daily
tactical planning sessions
where we have a team
of a dozen scientists,
and a dozen engineers
sitting together in a room,
and figuring out exactly
what we're gonna do
with the rovers on Mars
I bet you could sit there for an hour,
and still not quite figure out
who were the scientists
and who were the engineers.
The team is blended so well now
that I think you'd have a hard
time telling the difference.
- Now it's very clear
in reading your book,
and watching the movie
which is also very good
I should mention that
a Disney produced movie
with the same title Roving Mars
that you had the important
role of being the leader,
so you're not just a scientist
working with engineers
you're the leader of a science
mission project, so let's
talk a little about that role.
What are the characteristics
that make it work,
and how do you learn
as the process goes on?
- Well, you learn by making mistakes,
and doing the best you can.
I'm the leader of the
science team for the mission.
You can't boss scientists around.
You're not the general in an army
with a bunch of privates under
you that you tell what to do.
Scientists do what they do
because they love what they do,
and they're creative, and they work best
when they're allowed to
exercise that creativity.
The way we tried to lead on this project
in some respects I think
it was similar with the engineers, too.
I mean, we had a very, very
talented engineering team.
These are people who
had a tough job to do.
They needed to create something.
What you do when you're leading
a group of people like that
is rather than giving
them a lot of directives,
writing a lot of memos
and giving a lot of orders
what you want to do instead is
make sure everybody
knows what their job is.
You create a structure in which
everybody has a clearly
defined responsibility.
You make sure they know the processes
that they're supposed to
follow to get that job done,
and then you kind of stand back
and let the machinery work.
I think the best leader of
an organization like this
is one who gives no orders at all
that you create an
organization that runs so well
that you can take your hands
off and just let it go.
I'm proud that I think
we've achieved that.
I mean, I could get hit by a bus today,
and the rovers would never know.
My team is so good they don't
need me, they don't need me.
Another thing is if you
create an organization
in which any person the
leader or anybody else
is indispensable, irreplaceable
you've made a mistake.
If you're spending 900
million taxpayer dollars,
which we are,
you better not have anybody
who is just essential
because stuff can happen.
We've worked really hard
to create an organization
where everybody knows
their job, things go well.
I'm here at Berkeley today.
The rovers are gonna be operated.
The science team is gonna be meeting.
In fact, they're meeting
right now as we're speaking
now that I think about it
planning the next day's
worth of operations on Mars,
and I don't know what they're doing,
but I know they're doing it
well because they always do.
- It's an interesting
expression the rovers
when you use that expression
you're not just talking about the robots
you're talking about the
team that are actually part,
or was that just?
- Yeah, it all sort of
blends together in your mind
after a while.
We see these rovers as
extensions of ourselves.
We want to understand Mars.
We want to explore Mars.
If any of us had the ability
to strap on our boots,
and our space helmets and
go there ourselves we would.
Instead we experience Mars
through the rover's eyes.
We touch Mars with the rover's arm.
That eyesight, that arm
they're very human like.
Some of it's coincidence,
but some of it's quite intentional.
You see yourself as almost
being there virtually
through the rovers.
You're standing there on Mars kind of,
and you look around with
the cameras and you think,
oh, that looks interesting
let's go there and then you do,
and the next day you're there,
and there are pictures of what
you wanted to see closeup.
It's so much like being there.
Yeah, it kind of blends
together in your head
a little bit after a while.
- Now all this comes about,
and we'll talk a little more about
the rovers and the mission in a minute,
it's very interesting because
in your book you describe
that this particular project was kind of
the third or fourth proposal,
so you had to deal with the frustration
of writing proposals that weren't funded,
didn't win the competition.
Talk a little about that
because there is an
interface here big science,
big engineering teams,
but you have to go to the government
to be funded and win in a competition.
- Yeah, you do and that's
the way it should be.
There are a lot of ideas out there
for interesting things
that you can do in space,
and they all cost a lot of money.
I mean, an inexpensive planetary mission
costs half a billion dollars.
These are phenomenally expensive things.
There are lots of great ideas
out there far more good ideas
than you can actually fund and carry out,
so how do you decide what to fly?
It's largely via a competitive process.
Yeah, we went through a period, I mean,
I started writing proposals
for what eventually became
this mission in 1987.
We finally got selected four proposals,
and 10 years later in 1997,
and there was a string of
failed proposals in there.
Each one was better than the one before.
Frankly, the early ones
probably weren't good enough,
and they didn't deserve to be selected.
They weren't at the level of quality
that it made sense for
the American taxpayers
to invest hundreds of millions
of dollars on our idea
because our idea wasn't good enough yet.
It was bitterly disappointing
when you put years of effort,
and hundreds of thousands of dollars
into writing a proposal
and it gets shot down,
but looking back on it
they probably deserved to be shot down.
I can see the flaws,
and we got smarter, and we got better,
and we honed our ideas.
There was stuff that we
would have liked to have done
that we had to take out
because we had to make
compromises to make it all fit.
Then in the end, finally, 1997
after 10 years of writing proposals
we got selected to do a mission,
and then there was great
turmoil in the Mars program
we got flat out canceled,
and brought back to life three times.
It wasn't really until the year 2000
that we got the final go ahead from NASA
to build these two rovers.
We initially thought we
were gonna build one,
and then they decided to fly two.
Once they sort of made the decision,
and gave us the money we had
34 months to actually do it
before we had to be on top
of the rockets in Florida.
There was this brutally long
period of writing proposals,
and trying to get NASA to say yes,
and then once they finally said yes,
there was this brutally
short period of time
that we had to actually get it done.
- Let me, there's one point
I did want to bring out
because in your book there's
this beautiful description of
how each time you would
be writing a proposal
you would get a group together,
and you struggled with
a blank piece of paper,
and you sort of had to put it all down.
All of this losing,
then winning, actually competing,
but then bringing on board
former competitors and so on,
it was all part of that?
- Oh, yeah, it's this very
complicated evolutionary process,
and like you said it starts
with a blank sheet of paper.
The blank sheet of paper phase
is actually one of my favorite parts
of the whole space mission game,
but it's a scary part because, boy,
you can go terribly wrong in that phase,
and have very bad consequences downstream.
The blank sheet of paper is
literally you've got an idea.
I want to find out what
it was like on Mars
four billion years ago,
and could the conditions
there have supported life?
I know that the basic approach
to doing that sort of thing
that works on Earth is you
go and you do field geology,
and you look at the rocks,
and you read the story in the rocks,
so that's what I want to do.
Okay, now how do I do it?
I mean, how do I actually
build a piece of hardware
that you can strap on top of a rocket,
and shoot off to Mars and
it's actually gonna work?
You sit down and you
gather colleagues, friends,
people who you know who are really smart,
and good at this kind of stuff,
and you start throwing around ideas.
Well, we could try this,
well, we could try that.
Oh, man, we went through so many.
There were iterations of this mission
where the rover would descend
on this powered lander,
it would land, look around,
and then take off again,
and go land somewhere else,
we had all sorts of ideas.
Many of them turned out to be impractical
including that one.
You fill in that blank sheet
of paper with your ideas,
and then you put in a
proposal and you compete,
and you compete against other colleagues
who have similar ideas,
and maybe you succeed and maybe you fail.
Most of the time you fail.
When that happens it feels really bad.
Then you kind of regroup and you say,
okay, what are we gonna try now?
Sometimes, as you said,
you approach some of your
competitors and you say,
well, we've got a good idea,
but you've got a pretty
good idea there, too.
You want to team up maybe?
So there's a lot of
that stuff that goes on.
Yeah, we went through
10 years of that stuff
before NASA finally said yes.
- Help us understand better now why Mars.
You touched on that, I
mean, when you go from Mars
what is it that our audience
should understand about Mars,
and what makes it
attractive for a scientist
to go after the question
you're looking at?
- The thing that makes Mars important
is that it's one of the few
places in our solar system
that's enough like Earth
that you can imagine life
having once taken hold there.
In fact, while it's
sort of like Earth today
there's strong evidence, powerful evidence
that in the past it was more like Earth.
It was warmer, it was wetter,
there was liquid water at the surface.
You can see places on
Mars where it looks like
water pooled and ponded
and flowed and so forth,
so because water is such a
crucial ingredient for life
Mars becomes a compelling target
to try to answer the question of
are we the only life in the solar system,
or has life taken hold somewhere else?
Now Mars is not the only
place you can do that.
Another world that I'm very fascinated by,
and have been for years is Europa.
Europa is a big moon of Jupiter.
It has a crust of ice and
we think below that crust
may be an ocean of liquid water.
If I could figure out how
to do submarines on Europa
maybe I wouldn't be doing rovers on Mars,
but Mars is both important
to the question of life and
comparatively accessible.
You can actually build a robot,
and go to rock outcrops on Mars
that preserve evidence of
what it was like long ago,
and read that record,
and infer things about
what the planet was like.
That was what drove us was
it's the life question.
I mean, that's what makes Mars special.
- How far away is Mars?
If you're planning a vacation
how long is it gonna take to get there?
- You better be ready for a long trip.
Mars is,
you know, roughly 50% farther from the sun
than the Earth is.
Of course, the planets are always moving,
so the distance between Earth
and Mars is always changing.
When you launched from Earth to go to Mars
typical travel time is maybe seven months,
six to eight months it took
us seven months to get there.
That's long trip.
- Did you know how much money
you would have in the beginning,
or did the amount of money
you have change over time?
- Oh, my.
It changed.
When NASA first asked us to do this,
and told us they wanted two rovers
we did the very best we could
to estimate what it was gonna cost,
and I remember the number
it was $688 million,
and we were sure, I mean,
we had all sorts of margin
on top of that, you know,
we were quite confident in that number.
As it turns out we were wrong,
and our budget overran,
and in the end it cost about $800 million
to get the rovers to Mars,
and then we've spent another
$100 million since then
operating them so we underestimated.
That's not uncommon in the space business
you're trying to do something
that nobody's ever done before
so it's hard to guess
exactly what it's gonna cost
because it's difficult to foresee
the problems you're gonna encounter.
We encountered many terrible problems
in the process of building our rovers,
but fundamentally the bad ones
all stemmed from one thing.
We underestimated how
big the rover had to be
by about 10% just by a little bit, okay?
We had a design for a
lander, for a parachute,
for airbags all that stuff
that we had inherited
from a previous mission.
There was the Mars Pathfinder mission,
wonderful mission back in the mid '90s.
The idea we were just gonna
scoop out the interior
of the Pathfinder land it so
we have a big empty space,
and stuff our rover in there.
If the rover fit
we really could have
done it for $688 million,
but in the end the rover was
just a little too big to fit,
so the lander had to get bigger,
so everything got heavier,
so the airbags needed to be reinforced,
and the parachute had to be redesigned,
and everything changed.
We had to redesign the
whole landing system,
and that resulted in a cost overrun,
and, yeah, in the end it
cost about 800 million.
- Now this team that was working on
these sets of problems that
were changing over time
you attempt in the back of
your book to list them there
there are 4,000 plus really.
- The real number is
probably something like
six or seven thousand, I
couldn't find them all,
but, yeah, there were thousands of people
who worked on this mission.
- So organizationally
you confront a problem,
you mentioned one the parachute problem
the rover is getting bigger and bigger,
and you have eight months to launch,
and the parachute you
have sort of doesn't work.
Organizationally, what happens
as you confront that problem
is it clear the sub-group
that this problem goes to,
and they're off working on it and so on?
- Yeah, I mean, you have to have clearly
delineated responsibilities.
When a problem comes up
you got to be very certain
who owns that problem,
and whose responsibility it
is to find a solution to it,
so in the case of the parachutes
we had a small group of individuals
led by one very talented creative person
whose job it was to solve that problem.
The approach they took was,
man, we're almost out of time.
Let's develop three different
parachutes in parallel,
and hope that one of them
works and one of them did,
but that was a scary
problem and one among many.
I mean, we had all sorts
of terrible things go wrong
over the course of
developing these rovers.
To me it was a small miracle
that we even got to the
launch pad let alone Mars.
- When you think of a
scientist working in a lab,
and creativity the light bulb goes off
if we were a Disney cartoon
what is creativity
like in a group process like this?
In other words, is it that
you confront a problem
the right team with
the right relationships
working together and then a bulb goes off?
- It can work in different ways.
It depends on the particular problem,
and the nature of it.
It is very much a team effort.
These rovers are so complicated
that no one understands them.
There literally is no single human being
who understands these rovers.
They're just too complicated
for a single person to wrap
their head around completely.
As a team we understand them.
As a team there's somebody who understands
each part of the vehicle well enough
that as an organization we get it,
but when you're in the process of
creating something that complex
it's a mix, it's a mix because
there are some problems
that you really require group
interaction to deal with.
You've got some problem
that you're working on,
and it has many, many
different elements to it.
There's no single person
who is gonna be able to
solve that problem on their own.
In other instances there
were a number of things
that were solved by the
lone genius, if you will.
We had a lot of geniuses
on our team I think,
and one person somewhere
has some brilliant insight,
and then you go, oh yeah,
that's got to be it,
and you go charging off down that path,
but it was one person's
instant of creativity
when they saw the solution
that nobody else saw,
and I give some examples
of that in the book
that we had what looked like
some insurmountable problem,
and somebody goes, well,
wait, why don't we try this?
Everybody goes, by golly,
yeah, that's it, so it's a mix,
but looking at it I think
a lot of the most important
really creative moments in
the design of this thing
came from the insights
of specific individuals,
people whose job it was
to solve this problem,
and they just sat down and solved it.
- There's one episode
once the rovers are there
that sort of struck me.
Briefly you lose contact with the rover.
Yeah, you can't figure it out.
There was a problem with the flash drive.
It's very interesting because it was as if
the rover had died,
you're all running around.
- I didn't sleep for three days.
- But somebody, one
member of the team had--
- Glenn Reeves.
- Brilliant guy.
- It's an example of a kind of creativity
that anticipated something.
- Yes, that was a wonderful example.
Yeah, what happened was
18 days into the mission
we just lost contact with
Spirit just gone, nothing.
The way you troubleshoot
a problem on a spacecraft
is you look at the data that
you have in the telemetry
you figure out what's
going on and you fix it.
The only thing we had was no telemetry
that was really bad.
Then what happened was we
started to get just little blips
of data from the rover,
and we finally sort of got the sense
that what was happening was
the computer was booting up,
it recognized the problem it crashed,
and then it would boot up
again 15 minutes later.
It was doing this over and over and over,
and doing it during the night
when there's no solar power,
and the battery is going down
and down and down and down,
and sooner or later four
or five days of that,
and the vehicle is gonna die,
so we had a real problem on our hands,
and we didn't know what was going on
because we get these little
tiny fragments of data,
but what Glenn noticed
this was the breakthrough
was that Glenn started
looking at just these
little tiny blips of
data that we would get,
and what he noticed was that
it was all what we call real time data.
In other words, the rover is saying
here's what's happening to me now,
here's what's happening to me now.
None of it was this is
what happened an hour ago,
or a day ago, or three minutes ago.
It was all real time stuff,
and what that meant Glenn figured out
was that the rover had no memory.
It could only say what
was going on at the time.
During the development of the rovers
we had had a lot of problems
with the flash memory onboard the vehicle,
and because of that Glenn
had created this command
it was called, init.crippled,
initializing crippled mode.
What it does is rather
than using the flash memory
it builds a whole little
file system in RAM,
in the computer instead,
so we fired up based on his intuition,
an init.crippled command, and boom,
the rover regained its sanity immediately,
and it was a problem with the
flash management software.
Once we regained control of the vehicle,
and put it to sleep
to recharge the batteries
for a couple of days,
then it was possible to
figure out what was going on,
regain control and everything
was fine after that,
but there was that moment of insight
when Glenn realized, oh,
it's all real time data.
It's probably the flash.
That was the thing that saved the mission.
If it had gone for another couple days
we would have lost Spirit.
- Help our audience understand
the rovers basically.
- [Steve] Good luck with that.
- I realize we could
take hours doing that,
but just sort of briefly,
first, how were they named?
- Oh, yeah, Spirit and Opportunity
the way they were named was that NASA held
I don't know if I'd call it a competition,
but an activity with school children
across the country were invited to
write in and suggest names,
and write a short essay.
Then there was this process to select
the names from that pool.
The names Spirit and Opportunity
were suggested by a little girl
I think she was about nine
years old at the time.
She was from Arizona near Phoenix.
Her name was Sofi Collis.
She had been born in Russia,
and grew up initially
in an orphanage there.
She lived in an orphanage in Russia
until she was about I
think four years old,
something like that,
she, you know, at the age
of nine could remember
some of her time in the orphanage,
and then she had been adopted
by an American family,
and had come to the United States.
She wrote this very touching essay
it was like three sentences
long or something.
I mean, she's nine years old,
but she had picked the
name Spirit and Opportunity
to sort of represent her feelings about
the opportunity that she got
to come and start her life
over in the United States.
I've actually grown very
attached to those two names
I thought they were wonderful choices.
One of the things I liked about it is
those names sort of
follow in the tradition
of naming ships of
exploration after things
that express your hopes, your aspirations.
Endeavor, one of the space shuttles,
but also named after James Cook's ship
on his first voyage of circumnavigation,
great example of that,
and Endurance, Ernest Shackleton's ship.
I mean, there are many good
examples like that from history,
so I think Spirit and
Opportunity are great names.
- Interestingly enough
the names sort of worked
as you described what the two did
where Opportunity had opportunity
and Spirit had spirit.
- Spirit had a lot of spirit, yeah.
It's funny because the
rovers, yeah, I mean,
they're hunks of metal, okay,
I get that, they're robots,
but they're complicated enough.
They sort of have developed
a certain amount of personality, right?
We made them as identical as we could,
but, of course, they're so complicated
that they have differences
between them anyway.
- What can they do?
Talk as you're answering
the question, yeah, yeah.
- Then once we got them to
Mars we wound up operating them
in very, very different environments,
and in very, very different ways
so they've had very different experiences
since they got to Mars.
In Opportunity's case the
big scientific discoveries
all came in the first six weeks.
I mean, it was just right
there, right there, it was easy.
Spirit had to work for everything.
I mean, Spirit landed in this
horrible, rocky lava plain
with boulders strewn everywhere,
and had to struggle to get to these hills,
and then climb a mountain
to start finding the
really interesting science.
I mean, what the rovers do
is just what you would do if you there.
There are sort of three key components.
One is they can look around.
They've got very good cameras
with the equivalent of 20/20 vision.
Superman's got X-ray vision,
we got infrared vision.
We can look off in the infrared
and use that to figure out
what rocks are made of
from 50, 100 meters away.
When you find something interesting
the second thing they can do is move.
They can go over and just like you,
oh, that looks like an interesting outcrop
let's go look at that,
so you walk over to it,
okay, we drive over to it.
Then when you get close you
can investigate it in detail.
We've got this arm,
and it's got the same
dimensions as a human arm,
and on the end of it there's
this suite of sensors
that includes a microscope,
this thing we call a RAT
that can grind away the
outer layers of our rock.
We've got spectrometers
that can look at the rock,
and tell us what it's made of,
and those really gather the
in-depth clues that we can use
to figure out what happened here.
It's just this constant
process of discovery,
you know, you land with an idea.
At both landing sites
we landed with an idea
of what we were gonna find,
totally completely utterly wrong.
Could not have been more
wrong at both landing sites.
Okay, so then you kind of
regroup, and you say, okay,
this is different now
what are we dealing with?
You just explore.
It's so much like
what real geologists do on Earth
when they're in the field
and doing what geologists do.
It's real field geology on
another planet and that's fun.
- As you describe the humans on Earth
interacting with the robots
I had this sense that it
was a combination of an ER,
a family intervention,
and parents communicating
with their children
away at college who were
dealing with a problem.
Is that fair?
- Yeah, there are elements of that.
I would also throw in maybe operating
a robotic remote-controlled
car or something.
There are elements of
many aspects of that.
The rovers
we designed them to be as capable,
and as flexible as we could
sort of like a Swiss Army knife
you equip them with
lots and lots of tools.
You don't actually know what
tools you're gonna need.
I mean, the environment that
we were sending them into
was so poorly known
that we couldn't design
for that environment
because we didn't know what it was.
We didn't know what things
we were gonna encounter,
so you have to just kind of imagine
the things you might find,
and imagine the tools that might help you
figure those things out,
and then build those tools,
and cross your fingers
and hope for the best.
You get there and what you
find is not what you expected.
The tools you brought are pretty good,
but maybe not exactly
what you would have built
for the circumstances you encounter,
so then you start getting creative,
and you start figuring out
how to use the tools you got
to answer the problem
that Mars has given you
as opposed to the one
that you anticipated,
and you improvise, you make
up stuff as you go along.
We didn't know what we
doing when we landed.
I man, how can you know what you're doing
when nobody's ever done it before, right?
So you just figure it out as best you can.
Another element, of course, is that
you command the rover
to do certain things,
but all of those things depend on how
it interacts with Mars.
You turn the wheels to get it to go,
but, sometimes, the wheels
slip in the soil, okay.
You want to take a picture of something,
but you get close to it
and it doesn't look like
what you thought it was gonna look like.
Sometimes, you tell the
rover to do something,
and the result that you get
is not quite what you expected.
We've gotten them stuck in sand dunes,
all sorts of things have happened.
When that happens you just figure it out.
Also, stuff goes wrong.
I mean, things break.
These rovers are getting old.
They're seven years old and
hardware breaks on these things,
and when hardware breaks
you can't go up with a
screwdriver and fix it
you got to figure out
how to work around it.
There's this process of
just figuring out how to
deal with the unexpected.
That's part of what
makes the operations fun.
I mean, the constant discoveries,
the scientific discoveries
are tremendous fun,
but this challenge of taking
this thing that we built,
and trying to make it work
in this crazy, unexpected,
unpredictable environment
that's a fascinating challenge as well.
- In your lecture you said that the rovers
were programmed to have
courage to make choices.
Talk a little about that
because it's not all your guidance.
- That's right, I mean, when
you think about this the rovers
they're very far away.
A typical time that it takes to send
a radio signal to Mars
might be 10 minutes,
so you can't joystick it, you
can't operate it in real time
you have to send a set of commands.
Typically what we do
is we'll send an entire
Mars day's worth of commands all at once.
It gets those commands
first thing in the morning,
and then we don't communicate with it.
We told it what to do for
the day and it does it,
and at the end of day it
sends back the results.
Sometimes you have to
ask the rover to make its own decisions.
I mean, let's say we want
to drive long distances,
we want to drive, I mean,
with Opportunity right now
we're trying to drive
like 150 meters a day,
that's a long ways.
We have good cameras,
but the cameras are not good enough
to reliably spot dangerous obstacles
150 meters off in the distance
we just can't do that.
So you got two choices.
Either you can say we're only gonna drive
as far as we're confident we
can see which slows you down,
or you can trust the rover
to look at the terrain in
front of it on its own,
and make smart choices,
and we've built that
capability into the vehicle.
Typically, when we do a long drive
the first part of it maybe
the first 70 or 80 meters
we will command explicit,
and we'll just tell the rover go, okay?
We can see, we know it's safe just go,
go as fast as you can,
but then once you get 80 meters out
we want you to turn on your brain,
and we want you to start looking ahead,
and what the rover will
do is use its cameras
to look for obstacles.
It can do onboard stereo matching,
so it takes two images,
uses those images to build
up a three-dimensional model
of the terrain in front of it,
and it will assess what it sees.
If it looks smooth and
flat and smooth sailing
it will move forward.
If it sees an obstacle it
will look at that obstacle,
and say, well, is that little enough
that I can drive over it,
or should maybe I go around this thing?
Yeah, you can program different levels
of courage or cowardice.
You can make it scared
of only big objects,
or if you think it's
really dangerous out there
you can make it scared
of little tiny ones.
In that way the rover is able to
kind of pick its way through
what might otherwise be
risky, dangerous obstacles.
- What is the most
important thing you think
we've learned from this mission?
- Well, that's a hard question
it's been going on for seven years now,
and we've made many
individual discoveries,
but if you take the most
important individual discoveries,
and kind of wrap them together and say,
what have we really learned?
What we've learned is that in the past
Mars clearly had habitable
conditions on its surface.
There was liquid water below the surface.
There was liquid water that
came up to the surface.
There were hot springs.
There were volcanic vents
with steam coming out of them.
There were places that on Earth
are inhabited by microbial life.
Now that doesn't mean that
that happened on Mars.
Being habitable and being inhabited
are two different things,
but there clearly were
times and places on Mars
were conditions would have
been suitable for life,
so what that says is
if you want to know whether
there truly was life on Mars
you go to those places
with the right tools,
and you investigate the
question of was there life.
Maybe the best way is to bring rocks back,
and put them in the laboratories on Earth,
but was Mars once a habitable world?
Yeah, there were places
and times where it was.
- Now I know that you have been chairman
of an advisory committee
to sort of look at the
future of space exploration.
- Yes, that's been my other job
for the last couple of years.
- I mean, the country
is in a place where it has
to reassess its priorities,
and so on,
so how should we think about
what we should do in the future?
This mission was such a great success
in the sense that the
rovers have gone more than
how many days, I mean?
- [Steve] Today as we speak is day 2,586.
- So building on that
sort of great achievement
of scientific leadership
how should we think about the future?
- Well, we can talk just about Mars,
or we can talk more broadly.
As you say, one of the things that
I've been involved in recently
it's called the Planetary Decadal Survey.
It's a year's long process
of establishing priorities
for the next decade of
solar system exploration.
The conclusion from that process was that
the next thing to do at Mars
after we've completed the missions
that are in the works right
now is to bring samples back,
is to bring rocks back
from the Martian surface.
We've gotten to the point
where we know enough about Mars
that we know the good
places to go and it's
so hard to build instruments
that you can miniaturize,
and ruggedize and put on top off a rock,
and then send to Mars.
The best scientific instruments are always
gonna be back here on Earth,
so the next logical step for Mars
now that we've learned all
the things we've learned
is to find some of these
really critical rocks
that are most likely to
contain clues about life,
and bring them back to this planet.
So that is the next step for Mars,
but there are other great
places to go as well.
I mentioned Europa.
Europa is this moon of Jupiter
that we think has an ocean,
and it would be nice to
really understand that ocean,
so there's a mission
that we're looking at,
and thinking about that would
go into orbit around Europa,
and would carry a number of instruments.
An intriguing one is a
long wavelength radar.
I mean, radar at long wavelengths
can actually see through
kilometers of ice.
That's how we've mapped the
bottom of the Antarctic,
and the Greenland ice sheets.
Do that at Europa, find
out how thick that ice is.
Find out how deep you have
to go to get to the ocean.
Find where the thin spots are
so maybe some day in the distant future
we can go there and get
down into the ocean,
so that's a very exciting mission.
Another mission that
we're really excited about
is a mission to Uranus or Neptune.
They're basically three
different kinds of planets
in the solar system.
You've got the terrestrial planets,
Mercury, Venus, Earth,
Mars are made of rock.
We've explored those very well.
You got the gas giants Jupiter and Saturn
made mostly of hydrogen and helium.
We've explored Jupiter with Galileo.
We've explored Saturn
with the Cassini mission
which is going on right now,
and then you've got the ice
giants, Uranus and Neptune,
which they're made of
very, very different stuff
than Jupiter and Saturn are.
They're not like anything else,
and all we've done is
fly by each of them once
with Voyager 2 with 1970's technology,
so there's enormous potential
for discovery there,
so another future mission would be kind of
an orbiter and a probe
to go to one of those ice giant planets,
so those are some of the
really exciting things
I think on the horizon.
- How critical is this
work in our future in space
to maintaining American
scientific leadership?
- I think it's absolutely crucial.
I mean, if you look at the things that
our nation does scientifically
there are only a few really.
If you look at the capabilities that exist
in many countries now
there are only a few things
where we in the United States
are still the acknowledged world leaders,
and we do stuff that nobody else can do.
You know, high energy
particle accelerators
the Europeans are great at that, okay?
I mean, you can name all sorts of things
where the United States is
not the acknowledged leader,
but this is an area where we are.
Planetary exploration,
deep space exploration,
this is something that we
do better than anybody,
and if you want to talk
about maintaining leadership,
man, here's a great example.
- Finally, how would you
advise students out there
who might watch this to
prepare for the future
if they see their future is
involved in this kind of work?
- You know, it comes
down to the fundamentals.
When you're getting your initial training
it's blocking and tackling.
It's the really basic skills.
There's plenty of time once
you get into graduate school
to specialize and learn about this detail,
or that detail or what have you.
The foundation on which
all of this is built
is physics, chemistry, mathematics.
The real core sciences
that we need that form
the toolkit that you use
to do this kind of stuff.
We talked earlier about creativity,
and we talked earlier about insight,
and people's ability to
look at some tough problem
like a parachute that doesn't work,
or how do you position instruments
with a precision of
millimeters on another world.
Those problems were
solved by creative people,
but every single one of those
people had a solid background
in physics, mathematics,
the things that you need
the toolkit that you need
to solve problems like that.
I don't care how creative you are
if you don't have those tools
you're not gonna be able to do it,
so in the beginning it's just getting
that solid grounding and the fundamentals.
- Steve, let me show your book again.
I think people will really
find it fascinating,
and also there is an IMAX movie
which really gives you a visual sense
of a lot of what you were describing.
Thank you very much for
coming on our program.
- I enjoyed talking to you.
- Thank you very much for joining us
for this Conversation with History.
(upbeat music)